Speaker 1: I got dozens of emails from people
over the weekend, not over the weekend since
last night saying, David, you've got to talk about
what happened at the Oscars. Will Smith open hand
slapping a Chris Rock. And it was crazy and you've
got to talk about what happened. So we are going
to talk about this on the bonus show today. I
wanted to say just a couple of things about it.
I am not. Let me first explain what happened.
As I understand it, and I haven't watched the
Oscars in more than 10 years, but I watched
some clips and read some articles this morning.
Chris Rock joked about Will Smith's wife's short
haircut, Jada Pinkett Smith, which is apparently
short, at least in part because of the
medical condition alopecia baldness.
And Will Smith apparently didn't like it. And when
he walked up to the stage, he slapped Chris Rock.
And then when he sat back down, he was screaming
at him about Keep my wife's name out of your
mouth. The reactions exploded. Some people
reacting along racial lines saying that if this
was rather than two black men, a white man and
a black man, it would have been seen completely
different. One of them would have been arrested
or the other would have been arrested. OK, that
was one line of analysis. Another was this was
obviously staged because in no sane world would
this happen. And then the Oscars just. Continue.
I don't know that that's necessarily the case,
the people organizing the Oscars might have been
as shocked by what happened as anybody else, and
they didn't know what the hell to do. And
they're like, I guess we just continue the show.
I really don't know at this early point
in time what the truth is about this,
but it is one of the strangest things I've
ever even heard of happening during the Oscars,
and we are going to talk about it in more
detail on the bonus show. So I just wanted to
say a little something I want to hear from you.
If you're watching on YouTube, leave a comment
about what you think happened. Was this genuine?
Was this a setup as some are claiming? Let us
know. Let me know on Twitter at David Pakman
and then we'll talk about it on the bonus show